from the ecowas election Observer
Mission a tough assessment that the
voting process in Nigeria was marred by
irregularities among them
selves
am
opening time due to the late arrival
of pulling of officials
of particular concern to observers the
slow pace of uploading results to the
website of the independent National
electoral commission or inacc
for its part inec issued a statement on
Sunday saying the delays were the result
of technical hitches and not due to any
sabotage
but in a country with a history of
ballot rigging and vote buying many
weren't that reassured
we're in Abuja there's growing concern
the longer it takes to get the official
election results the more likely people
will distrust the ultimate outcome
pharmacist David onoja said he expected
a more transparent process and that he's
growing suspicious
we will do that the Collision Center
will open it will close it will open it
will close and we began to wonder they
promise that it will be transmitted
electronically but we didn't see it
Civil Service
who told us she acted as a poll worker
on Election Day is also worried
currently in patients really want to
know who won and how the Electoral
courses are being taken care of among
voters disappointment among politicians
discontent
the unfortunate
tension spilled over in the voter
collation center with some party
Representatives storming out of the
proceedings
at stake in this hotly contested
election the presidency as well as
hundreds of seats in Parliament in his
preliminary findings the EU election
observation Mission Nigeria said
planning for the polls had been
insufficient we also called on All
actors
act a kind of disputes that they should
be dealt with through legal procedures
while 18 candidates are running for
president only three are seen as having
a realistic chance at winning but with
each of those Front Runners claiming
they're on the road to Victory concern
is growing that things may only get more
heated
Abuja